some very interesting discussions I
spotted this morning on the David Pakman
show subreddit which you can participate
in at david pakman.com slash our EDD IT
nearly 7,000 of you now doing that there
was a reposting of my 2017 interview
with none other than jordan peterson and
I actually ended up reviewing this
interview because it got posted to our
subreddit and called to my attention it
really wasn't a bad interview I actually
was when I went back sometimes I look at
old interviews and I say I really did
not manage that interview well but the
Jordan Peterson one really wasn't bad
and I encourage people to check it out
on our channel enjoyable for families
and friends of all ages I didn't know at
that time that Jordan Peterson would
become a household name at least the
thumb what he has become in some
households he is a household name that's
absolutely right
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit Muller investigation
unconstitutional the new myth number two
yeah this is a good write up pointing
out that there is a movement that is
looking not just to discredit Robert
Muller for political bias or as an
individual but to argue that the mere
existence of Robert Moeller's
investigation actually violates the
Constitution and of course there's no
indication whatsoever that it does there
of course reasonable legal questions
about the indictment of a sitting
president or impeachment and and sort of
individual elements but there is really
no good case to be made that this is an
unconstitutional and investigation but
there is a movement that is arguing that
and that movement is outlined very
clearly on the subreddit also from the
David Pakman show subreddit has anyone
else unsubscribed from secular talk with
Kyle kolinsky shotsfired across the bow
that a lot of people in the audience
saying they are not unsubscribing from
kyle kolinsky secular talk while a
contingent of our audience chiming in on
this thread and saying yes i have
unsubscribed from secular talk but i
don't know that there's anything really
beyond anecdotal evidence to make of
that I mean both secular talk with Kyle
kolinsky and the David Pakman show as
channels continue to grow yes I mean
certainly different perspectives which
is all well and
I still watch Kyle's videos I like his
show yeah I support the free market of
ideas and people you know insert free
speech warrior talking points here I
don't even have to do it you're bored by
it by now I'm sure and lastly from the
david pakman show subreddit more reviews
of the possible new theme songs and I'm
not gonna read them one by one to you
but to summarize them a lot of people
are liking the latest addition to the
possibilities by a band or artist called
Philo's cult and the s and Philo's is
the dollar sign a lot of people really
liking that one so at some point we'll
do like an official poll and see what
people actually want